[Music]
the number two executive at facebook
says mistakes were made and there will
be changes the social media company is
facing a privacy scandal that has
sparked investigations in the US and
several other countries and sent chief
operating officer Sheryl Sandberg on a
media apology tour she spoke with dana
perino this afternoon at Facebook
headquarters dana joins us now live from
Enloe Park California
good evening Dana how out of Sandburg
planted calm the fears well thanks for
having me on the show Bret they
certainly have recognized one thing
which is the first step to recovery is
admitting that you have a problem they
did that in spades over the week saying
that they recognize they have a problem
they have personal responsibility and
that they're going to try to do
something about it but the scope and
scale of the problems that Facebook has
right now is almost unimaginable and I
asked her about how big the company's
gotten its Facebook getting just too big
I mean it's part of the success of the
business it's gotten so big if 2 billion
users can you hire enough people to
actually keep up with that at our size
and scope we have real responsibility
and we know that people have that
question and it's a question we're
answering we are ramping as quickly as
possible so that what they're trying to
do is to say that they've gone from
10,000 people that and they're hiring
another 10,000 so that's good right
there's jobs but you imagine now you
have 20,000 people trying to deal with 2
billion users it still feels like a
problem that is just a little bit out of
their control and certainly they're
going to be asked about that next week
when Mark Zuckerberg testifies in front
of Congress that'll be a big moment what
is the strategy for Facebook going into
those hearings next week well one of the
things they've done this week is to try
to soften up the ground they've had
several policy announcements of showing
that they are taking some action for
example today right before the show at
2:00 o'clock they announced that they
are going to deal something do something
about the political ads to make sure
that you know where those ads are coming
from who is funding them and if there's
any problems with it you will be alerted
and the person that put up that ad will
be alerted so they're trying to show
that they're getting ahead of the
problem
I also think that this what they want to
do next week is to show that Facebook is
focusing on the future but you and I
know breath that the members of Congress
aren't necessarily going to let them do
that they're going to make them pay for
the problems of the past before they can
do that isn't part of the necessary step
but you could also see regulation coming
out of this that will not only affect
Facebook but all of the tech companies
out here in Silicon Valley that was an
interesting interview and you can see
the rest of it online Dana as always
thank you thank you